good morning good afternoon good evening
depending on where you're joining us
from welcome to simply learn we are
honored to have you join us today for
utilizing social media marketing to
build an omni-channel strategy for
growing your business with your host
lalak Bullock my name is Richard and
after this intro I'll be mostly in the
background helping Lee lack so that
everything goes smooth utilizing social
media marketing to build an omni-channel
strategy for growing your business I
love the sound of growing a business
whether my own or helping others to
succeed leveraging social media
marketing to do so it helps your
personal career become more marketable
and helps whatever business you are in
working with succeed utilizing
omni-channel techniques keeps it smooth
and enjoyable retaining more customers
and being a better user experience if
you do not know belak hold on one second
there we go if you do not know Lee lack
Lee lack is mentioned in Forbes is one
of the top 20 woman and social media
power influences I've been mentioned in
career experts number one top digital
marketing influencer mentioned by Oracle
where she won the title of social
influence or of Europe attends the
Downing Street for best mum preneur of
the year Global Connections for women
foundation has awarded her global woman
champion award for outstanding
contribution and leadership in the
business as a number of one top seller
book on Amazon in cellars and marketing
category and as often mentioned in forms
Telegraph wired prima magazine Sunday
Times The Guardian kissmetrics social
media today and radio 5 live we are
honored to have her speaking here today
for those who are not familiar with this
former webinar I want to introduce you
to your dashboard if everybody could go
ahead and locate your dashboard and
locate the question module go ahead and
type in hello there and just let Li like
know you're excited to be here this also
helps us double check our sound system
and make sure everything is working
correctly
the way this works is you can go ahead
and answer ask questions in the question
section in the last 15 minutes we'll
collect those questions and have a
question answer period and try to get to
all the questions we can in that time
period but on the social media you can
mention sin your social media hashtag SL
webinars you know so if you're using
Facebook Twitter whatever social media
you like go ahead and bring us up in
there let people know you were here make
them wish they were here with us special
thanks to simply learn and for
sponsoring this cost it takes a lot to
put these webinars together so we really
appreciate having simply learn sponsor
these webinars they're a global online
training leader with over five hundred
thousand attendees working with over
2,000 enterprises and over 400 courses
because of their highly engaged blended
learning model over seventy two percent
course completion rate highest in the
industry simply learn is truly the
leader in global online training now you
didn't come here to listen to me so go
ahead and sit back relax have a cup of
coffee a cup of tea or if it's evening
where you're at maybe a glass of wine
I'm excited to hand this over to Lee
lack hello Lee lack and welcome to
simply learn today hi how are you thank
you so much for the warm welcome I'm
truly humbled by that introduction so
cake well so maybe deserve it so hello
everyone and thank you so much for
taking the time to listen to me so in
this presentation I'm going to be
talking to you about the omni-channel
experience what it is and why it should
matter to you so the omni-channel
experience is the future of marketing an
integrated seamless personalized
experience where the customer is at the
center of your focus and we will be
talking about the omni channel marketing
strategy how it can be implemented some
examples of brands have successfully
implemented an only channel strategy and
where social media fits into
all of this only channel is one of the
latest buzz words to take the marketing
world by storm the truth is it's
actually been around for a while now but
only until recent years has it really
started to gain traction in the
marketing community the ways people
interact with business has been in
constant and quite drastic change over
the past 10 or so years mainly due to
the internet and social media this has
led to different ways in which
businesses market and promote themselves
and particularly in the way as their
customers interact with them and even
more importantly is that customers have
different much higher expectations from
businesses when it comes to the buying
process and customer service only
channel is the response to this need and
the next logical step in marketing a
personalised seamless experience for the
customer from start to finish in order
to understand what only channel means we
can look at the terminology omni comes
from the word on this which means
universal or everything basically
omni-channel marketing means creating a
seamless shopping experience where
customers and potential customers can
easily switch between channels whether
they be mobile a physical store or
social media now bear with me one I
trying to explain what an omni-channel
marketing strategy is one of the biggest
developments in marketing and the way
companies sell their products is that
customers now have access to a lot more
information from various different
sources its own longer a case of wanting
to get something going to the shop you
know sells it and that's it the end now
people can firmly research products
online check out reviews see what social
media has to say and so on while they
can also engage with companies on
various different platforms it is the
reason why multi-channel marketing has
popped up and gained so much ground so
quickly companies have had to face the
fact
customers are spending a lot of their
time on different platforms whether it
be mobile social media or the web
therefore they needed to make sure that
we're maximizing these channels to put
things simply the omni-channel strategy
acknowledges that customers will likely
be using different channels at the same
time and aims to make the most of that
by creating the best most seamless
experience for the customer the most
important thing to remember about an
omni-channel strategy is that the
customer should be at the center of the
company's marketing efforts and I will
be sharing some examples with you soon
so that you can see exactly how a
company can employ an omni-channel
strategy and how it has benefited them
as well as some examples of how not to
do it I'm sure by now you're thinking
this all sounds great but what exactly
is different between an omni-channel
strategy and a multi-channel strategy
because let's face it they actually
sound very similar and you're right to
ask yourselves there our first glance is
kind of difficult to see what the
differences could be between those two
strategies after all marketing after all
sorry multi-channel marketing is all
about using different channels to reach
your customers and I'm sure you've heard
a million times how important it is not
to only have a presence on various
channels but also to make sure you're
being consistent across these different
channels once you take a deeper look
though it starts to become quite clear
that there are some substantial
differences between the two strategies
they're closely connected sure but they
are different the multi-channel strategy
has gained a lot of ground because
companies have had to face the fact that
their customers are spending a lot of
their time on different platforms like
mobile social media the web and others
and so they needed to find a way to make
sure that they have a presence on these
channels as well so that they don't lose
any opportunities
the thing is a multi-channel Stroh to
inconsistencies and the customer will
not have the same experience on each of
the channels after interacting the
company on a channel they will come out
with a different viewpoint that they
would if they were using a different
channel and that is a problem because
they are very likely to have to use that
different channel at some points or even
worse there can be used in the two
different channels or more at the same
time or rather in the same session in
fact for example forty-three percent of
customers have used their mobile device
were shopping in a physical store at
number is only expected from now on here
as we become even more attached to our
devices here's a scenario that you
probably found yourself in a few times
as a customer imagine you're in a
physical store looking to buy a laptop
one in the store you might using your
phone to look up the specs for the
laptop another laptop so that you can
compare you might even want to ask the
store a quick question and send them a
DM a direct message on twitter if the
staff is busy as customers we're now
expecting that the company will be able
to not only answer your questions as
soon as possible but the transition
between the channels will be seamless
another thing that could happen and has
definitely happened here at least a few
times is that you could be in a bricks
and mortar store and searching through
their products on their online store at
the same time and then you find what you
want to get on the website but when you
go to also start and store about it you
find out that they actually don't have
it in stock at that location and that's
a problem it's simply not a good
experience with a customer in fact they
most likely won't become a customer now
that you don't have what they want when
you make them believe that you did it
with your website and show this might be
acceptable the norm even but it's
changing customers expectations are
changing very very fast and busy
need to keep up the omni-channel
strategy acknowledges that customers are
using all of these different channels at
the same time and switching between them
so they put their customers at the
absolute center of their strategy every
channel is there to create the best
possible experience a deeply
personalized experience to sum this all
up a multi-channel strategy means using
different platforms and it channels to
communicate to and with the customer an
only channel strategy on the other hand
aims to create a personalized seamless
transition between different channels
with a physical or digital it will look
at the customer first and considers how
he or she want to engage with your
company and the customer switches
between channels constantly so the
question is can companies and businesses
keep up with this when it comes to sales
and customers one thing is for sure
maternal customers are much more
valuable than new customers for your
overall ROI in fact repeat customers
generate fifty percent of total revenue
generally and just one repeat customer
that leaves means you will need to
acquire five new customers to make up
for it only channel marketing is all
about retaining customers and even more
so building better relationships with
them and increasing their loyalty
through omni channel marketing you will
be able to connect with your customers
on a deeper level make more personalized
recommendations and improve their
loyalty which in turn can massively
improve your ROI with only channel
strategy in place you will also be able
to learn more about your existing
customers what channels they use how
they use them what they like to buy and
where and so on the more you know about
your customers the better you will be
able to market to them and make your
messaging more personalized when you
reach out to them this in turn will help
improve your sales and your overall
return on investment later on our share
with you some examples of companies
using only channel marketing
successfully and how they are improving
their ROI give me I'm sure you're all
thinking this has great in theory but
how exactly can i implement an
omni-channel strategy is it just another
buzzword that sounds good and marketers
like throwing around or can I actually
take advantage and use it for me the
answer is yes yes you can and although
you might not have the budget of a
company like Disney or Nike to help you
create the best possible strategy there
is still quite a lot you can do with
digital channels particularly with
social media the first thing that you
should do is put yourself in your
customers shoes so that you can truly
understand what the process is like for
them in a variety of different scenarios
for this you can either do it yourself
with the help of some of your team
members and friends or you can hire
specialists just like you would for
let's say a website optimization project
these are some of the scenarios that you
should be researching as a customer the
first stage is when they are researching
a product how easy is it to find the
information you need about your products
or services the thing is consumers have
different ways of researching some do it
in the store others do it online only
and an increasing amount consumers
combines the two by researching online
and in-store as well and this can be at
the same time all at different times so
it's important to look into the
different behaviors and find out how
easy it is to research your products and
services in all of the different
scenarios now on to customer service if
you have any questions or comments to
make our customer services you what does
the process look like which channels can
you use are you getting different
responses from different channels these
are all very important questions that
you need answered I'll give you a short
example and it's a situation I'm sure
you've all been in at some point in your
lives as well as some of you I'm sure
have had much worse customer service
experiences recently I've been having
some issues with my internet and my
broadband provider I'm not going to name
any names but I'm starting to think that
they're all interchangeable anyway
anyway back to the story my internet
wasn't working properly so i had to
point out the multiple times get
distorted I mean I'm saying multiple I'm
saying I had to contact them dozens of
times I spent literally hours with them
on the phone online on social media and
to be completely honest with you I'm
still mad just thinking about it what
really annoys me about the whole
experience is not just the fact that my
internet wasn't working properly but the
fact that every time I spoke with him I
had to explain everything from start and
I do mean everything including past
interactions with other employees not
only there but i would get different
responses and solutions depending on the
channel i was using to contact in the
end after hours and hours of talking to
them negotiating and frankly getting
increasingly fed up with them they
realized that if they wanted to keep me
on as a customer they had to give me
something anything really so they made
me a good offer more channels on my TV
better internet and so on but then when
I wanted to implement this offer and I
realize I wasn't talking to them what I
mean by this is that it wasn't the
company as a whole that made me that
offer it was just one department I mean
it came time to make use of his offer it
turned out that that offer shouldn't
have been made in the first place and
from there a new nightmare started who
made me that when did I talk to them but
what time what was the name of the
person who offered me this package was I
sure I heard it correctly oh
this point in her turned into an
interrogation long story short I got fed
up massively so not only was each
channels experience completely and
utterly different but the different
departments were even capable of making
the same decision or taking the same
stance that I was dealing with several
completely different companies at the
same time to be honest it was far from
an omni-channel experience as I've ever
encountered and these are the types of
situations you should be looking into
when researching your company's customer
service so ask yourself are your
customers getting the same response no
matter the channel they're using so one
of your customers let your social media
team know of an issue they're having
some trouble with one of your products
and they get a reply saying sure we look
into it are they actually going to pass
that information off to the right people
and get back to the customer in a timely
fashion or will the customer have to
contact a different Department and
explain the same as you again so they
can finally get some support there are
many ways in which customer service can
go on and it's very important that your
channels are truly interconnected and
designed in such a way so as to help the
customer that's all you really need to
know the customer has to be at the
center of your marketing efforts anyway
let's get back to what scenarios you
should be researching and this is
another very important one when the
customer is in the process of buying
something from you you might have a
physical store or have a digital one
only it doesn't really matter as the
principles are essentially the same if
you're selling anything we should put
yourself in the custom shoes to find out
what the buying process is truly like
what you need to consider is that buying
process is starting to get increasingly
complex and consumers are using more
channels when buying purchase patterns
are increasingly becoming a legion it's
no longer a case of customers seeing a
product they like
going to the closest store and buying
all those sure this customers still
exists but this is changing very rapidly
and companies need to keep up by putting
yourself in your customers shoes you
will know where to start with your
company's omni-channel strategy which
channel see more work and which channels
aren't properly integrated remember
though that there are different types of
customers and different ways of buying
researching and interacting with the
company so you'll need to go through all
of these different scenarios in order to
start implanting your own omni-channel
strategy you should create a list of
goals of course the ultimate goal is to
create a seamless integrated experience
across all of your different channels if
you want to achieve that you need to
communicate your goals to your various
departments and their people managing
them from the star who will be directly
involved with the customer experience to
your social media manager and all the
way up to the top executives it is also
important to make them understand the
need for communication within
departments is the only way really to
make sure that they are creating a truly
integrated experience for the customer
because that's what omni-channel means
all of the different channels and
platforms working together in order to
achieve the ultimate goal an integrated
customer experience where the user can
easily switch between channels and get
the same positive experience across them
all of these massive changes in consumer
behavior that we've been talking about
and largely due to the digital world we
live in that all of the different
channels we are using now we're using on
a daily basis mobile email and
particularly social media they've shaped
the way we interact not only with each
other on a personal level but also with
companies social media is a big part of
that as more and more people are using
it to engage with businesses in
different stages of the buying process
when we say
products and services we're making the
decision to buy and when they are
encountering any issues and our inland
of customer service this means that
businesses have to make an effort to
make sure that their social media
strategy is truly integrated with all of
their other channels first of all you
need to know your customer where are
they spending their time online what
social channels are they losing you can
then decide what the perfect platforms
are for your business but in order to
make your social media part of your Omni
channel marketing strategy you need to
take things a little bit further it's
important here to have a good social
media marketing tool to help you deal
with your audience you need to be able
to easily listen to your audience
analyze their behavior as well as be
able to respond to any mention question
or customer service issue in real time a
good tool can help you do that
particularly if it also has some
marketing automation capabilities to
help you sort your audience and make
sure you never miss any important update
I would recommend you try to like agoura
post which is what I'm currently using
for my social media as it not only helps
you manage your social media more easily
but they also have a great CRM tool
where you can leave notes ID tag see all
past conversations with the user and
much much more it also provides some
good monitoring capabilities for social
media that will help you listen to your
audience and stay on top of any brand
mentions and customer service is it all
make social media is so great in dealing
with customers and potential customers
is that it allows you to truly connect
with your audience on a personal level
which on the end of the day is what all
new channel marketing is all about a
personalized experience
employing an omni-channel strategy
you're basically recognizing that each
one of your customers is unique and that
they have their own individual needs and
expectations which you need to
acknowledge social media allows you to
create a personalized experience for
each and every one of your customers
which is what your audience expects each
customer wants to be special and
acknowledged appropriately by the
company they're spending their
hard-earned money in order to do that
it's more than just a case of knowing
their name and using it you need to know
everything there is to know about that
customer when I'm where have they
interacted with your business and the
past what is you have they asked how
they contacted a different Department
betwee for tweeting you or leaving an
update on your Facebook page one way of
dealing with this is to have a strong
customer relationship management
strategy home every time someone in your
company interacts with a particular
customer the details of that interaction
should be stored in one central place so
that anyone can easily access it on the
fly this will truly help you tools
achieving a personalized experience for
all of your customers social me
is a great platform for managing your
customer service and whether we like it
or not customers think so too it's much
more convenient for them to send out a
tweet informing you of a problem or to
ask you a question rather than to wait
an hour or on hold to get to speak to an
actual person rather than a robot so
your social audience will be using
Twitter or Facebook or whatever platform
they're on to call you out when they
have an issue or so to get some
customers support this means that
whoever is managing your social media
needs to respond promptly in real time
to any comment or question while also
personalizing their response not only
that but they need to have the necessary
knowledge to handle any customer service
issues in order to be able to do this
it's useful to have that central
database of customers that we talked
about earlier this way you can
personalize your response to any issue
and you will also be aware of any past
conversations with that particular user
even if they took place on a different
Channel there are brands that take
customer service to the next level and
as a result they get amazing coverage
from their very pleased customers delta
hotels now one of these types of brands
is delta hotels Mike McCready was
attending a conference in Vancouver and
while there he was staying at the delta
vancouver suites as you can see his view
really wasn't the best so he sent out an
Instagram with a photo of the views
saying the inside of my room at the
delta is really nice for the view not so
much Mike didn't tag delta hotels in his
update and as he mentioned in a blog he
posted about the experience afterwards
he wasn't exactly expecting anything
from them it was just a comment a fun
Instagram but delta hotels were
listening and came back to him within an
hour on twitter searching platforms and
offering to help why don't want to
switch rooms since he was leaving the
next day anyway so there wouldn't be a
point so
two hotels then asked him to send a
direct message so they could give him
some tips for any future bookings that
he might make which as you can imagine
Mike appreciated the fact that Delta was
listening to him and wanted to create a
better experience for him even when he
is when it wasn't necessary but the best
part came after when he came back to his
room after the conference and had a
lovely surprise from Delta Vancouver
sweets some sweets and a handwritten
note from the hotel this impressed Mike
and I'm sure they've turned him into a
return customer not only that but he
also wrote a post about it on his blog
and spread the word about the nice
gesture and there really is no better
form of marketing room word of man this
is a great example of how companies can
deal with customer service and turn what
is potentially a damaging situation for
them into not just a happy customer but
an amazing PR opportunity another sign
of great customer service is when the
company is able to employ some witnesses
in their response when the situation
would witness sorry witness in their
response for the situation calls bro of
course sainsbury's have done a great job
with this as when a customer was looking
to buy some battered fish in their local
store but it didn't have a bar chord so
who next answer is no on Twitter as you
can see sales were does not have not
only been quick to respond but though
reply was in the same vein as their
customers from there it on zoomed into a
funny conversation filled with fish
patterns while also making sure the
issue multi encountered was sold these
aren't even all of the twins after this
conversation there were dozens more
messages shared and all of them have
attracted lots of engaging and positive
publicity for Sainsbury's
as you can see from these examples even
when your customers are having issues
and complaining about them in the most
public web via social media it can still
be turned into a situation that actually
works to our advantage you could be
attracting positive media coverage like
an adulterer hotels case or you could
show that email as a brand you still
have a personality like same space did
whatever the case is if there's
something to learn about from these
examples it's that you should be
listening and monitoring constantly on
social media that any mentions of your
brand and when possible think outside
the box and go above and beyond for the
customer one of the ways to make social
media a part of an integrated
omni-channel strategy is to connect your
email marketing social media can help
you get more subscribers an email can
help you in turn by getting you more
engagement or social media basically is
a win-win situation when you integrate
the two now let's talk about how email
can help you get better results on
social media as a first step you should
include links to your social channels in
all of your emails when using trick
marketing one of your first emails to
present the social channels you are
active on and explain to your subscriber
why they should be following you
complete with a link that they can click
to to directly go to your social account
you can also use email to promote any
social media campaign you might be
holding for example if you're holding a
contest on Facebook send out an email
broadcast to your subscribers to let
them know about the contest tell them
what they need to do in order to win and
advertise the prize that could be
winning if they participate this
promoter
contact it goes both ways you could also
get more email subscribers by using
social media for example you can create
twitter cards that allow all your
followers to subscribe to list make sure
however that you give your audience of
good reason for subscribing then you can
also use your social platforms to share
the benefits to joining your list for
example so you set up a campaign where
you are offering your list and awesome
promotion like for example they're
getting twenty-five percent off on all
of your products for one week if and
then advertises on social media send out
an update when you let your fans and
followers know is what they could be
getting if they join your email list
excuse me another way to integrate email
and social is to upload your hard-earned
subscriber list your social media
accounts you can do this on most social
networks including twitter facebook
google+ and linkedin this can help you
in multiple ways one of these ways is by
using oil is to get more information and
insight into your audience the more you
know about them the more likely you are
excuse me the more you know about them
what makes them tick what their
interests are the better you can
personalize your emails and your social
updates and the more you can personalize
your emails the better chances you have
of making more conversions likewise on
social media when you write better
targeted updates you increase your
chances of getting more engagement more
clicks and traffic and so on and after
all that's what the only channel
experience all about personalization and
the customer once you start following
the members of your email list on social
media you should also use the
opportunity to interact with them this
leads to more followers and better
results on social plus you're truly
cementing these valuable relationships
as you're taking them a bit further
you're not just sending them email
broadcast anymore you're starting to
build real relationships with them
across platforms another way to use your
subscriber list is to create a targeted
social media ad campaign when you're
creating a social media
although most networks have great
targeting abilities targeting your
subscriber list directnic can get you
even better results think about it
they've already hit subscribe so not
only do they know about you and your
brand but they're already interested in
hearing more about you all more from you
in fact they might be in your list
because they're considering buying from
you well because they've already bought
something from you and might be willing
to buy more so who better to target them
in order to increase your ad campaign
success social media offers business is
an amazing tool will not allow them to
gain more insight into their customers
and their audience and ever before why
should we be doing that well there are a
lot of benefits but first let's go
through the type of information you
could be gathering about your audience
with the help of social media first you
can learn more about their passions and
hobbies what makes them tick basically
this allows you to personalize the
experience you create for each customer
which leaves in turn to a better
relationship another thing you will be
learning is what social media platforms
they prefer using particularly when
dealing with complaints and customer
service issues for businesses you will
then know which social networks you
should focus your attention and
resources on so that you can always
respond promptly to any issues and
questions so and also be able to glean
more insight into what types of devices
they're using on a day-to-day basis as
well as their movements if they're using
local location features on their social
accounts the more data you can gather on
your audience the better of course it's
not just an issue of collecting as much
data but also of knowing how to use it
to your advantage Disney is one of the
best examples on only channel marketing
strategy done right down to the smallest
details they've always been great at
marketing and they often one step ahead
and now they're setting the bar for
omni-channel experiences in my
you're planning or taking your trip to
designate the whole experience starts
the moment you reset your trip and buy
the tickets it continues when you get to
the destination and end well after you
return back home the whole experience
not only feels personal but it also
serves the purpose to make your whole
trip better more exciting more fun for
the whole family including the parents
and generally more stress-free which is
which is exclusively for the parents
Disney have fine-tuned each step of the
way research in the parks and relatives
buying your tickets preparing for your
trip get into the hotel and they
experience once you're actually in the
park let me explain how they do this so
of course you start by researching the
parks that you can decide what to buy
there are two main channels that you can
use for that the Disney website and
their app what's really great about it
is that you explore all different
attractions like rise restaurants and
other entertainment and even start
planning for once you get there by
creating wish lists and creating your
itinerary their website works
beautifully both on desktop and on
mobile devices which is a must because
people are likely to switch between
channels when buying something so for
example you're waiting on the tube have
some time to lose and you want to
surprise the family with a nice trip and
you get on disney's website to see if
disney world would be a good option for
what you're looking for the tube is fine
there while are being squeezed between
other commuters you forget about disney
well for a second then your home and you
want to continue your research and maybe
get those tickets there's no need to
keep using your phone now so you're
probably going to open up your computer
to finish the research and buy once
you've decided and bought your tickets
you can use the my Disney experience to
start planning your trip this could turn
into a fun experience for the whole
family or night memories depending on
what your kids want once you've arrived
at your destination you'll receive
Disney's Magic
customizable whispering which you can
use as a hotel key as a fast possible
rise ticket for the part and generally
as the primary payment method once you
like to see you out not only that but
earlier pictures taken in the part by
professionals will be registered to your
risk friend and instantly upload it to
the Disney now the disney app is another
really cool feature with it you can
explore the parks virtually directly on
your friends make plans but your
restaurant find out and get around the
park and find out what the wait times
are for different rides so that you
don't need any time basically anything
you could possibly need to have a great
experience designer in your phone or on
your wrist and as you can imagine this
makes the whole treat much fun relax for
everyone involved and while you're
having a great time at disney world
disney is collecting a load of data on
your behavior and using it to optimize
the experience even further this is a
great example of an omni-channel
strategy done mine disney are clearly
putting the customer fast and they're
striving to create the best possible
experience for them they are not only
giving their customers what they want
and expect they're actually going above
and beyond to impress them with a
seamless experience which means that
when someone leaves disney well they do
so with a smile on their face which
makes them much more likely to come back
and tell their friends about the amazing
time they've had and I'm sure by now
you're thinking that while all this
sounds great in theory most businesses
don't exactly have the resources that
tis me have to create this kind of
omni-channel experience which is true
there are very few companies that could
do this but there is a lot to learn from
Disney and strategy that they've created
it's just a question of finding the
right strategy for your business and
using the resources you have to create a
better more integrated seamless and
personalized experience for your
customers
is a very interesting mark first off
it's a huge one the population reaches
over 1.25 billion people which makes it
one of the largest in the world now so
the Indian market has very special needs
with most people preferring to buy in
store rather than online and not to
mention they're more likely to own a
smartphone and a desktop computer
hearing this you might be wondering if
there's even a need of omni-channel
marketing in India and well there is
only channel marketing is actually
exploding right now in India and I'm
very curious to see what the future will
bring as I mentioned earlier the
majority of Indian shoppers prefer to go
install rather than buy online so
companies in India have had to think
outside the box on how to improve the
customer experience install and with how
to seamlessly integrate digital with
their bricks and mortar shop burner
hostin is one of these companies and
they've done an outstanding job once you
hear how their Indian flagship store
words you'll probably want to buy a
plane ticket to go and see if yourself
what the future retail shopping looks
like first things first once you enter
the store you'll head right into the so
called today's briefing which is a 42
inch display digital display which gives
you relevant information about the
stores such as new additions styling
tips as well as the look of the day
among other info that's all great but
what comes next is much more impressive
just next to the today's briefing
display there's a fit scanner which is
basically an infrared device where you
can quickly scan yourself to find out
all of your exact measurements so that
you can find the best possible fit the
clothes you want to get now that you
know your measurements is time to find
some clothes to buy luckily there's a
style ball digital display where you
answer a few questions about your star
and get personalized recommendations for
up to 20 different looks to match your
personal style what's even more amazing
is that if you want to see how you would
look like wearing them you don't even
need to step into a changing rather you
can use the virtual trial mirror which
lets you try on the clothes virtual the
van hoosen shop in india
a truly exemplary way of integrating
digital into physical stores and I for
one can't wait to see more shops using
this type of technology to make shopping
and immersive and highly entertaining
experience with Disney we saw what the
complete omni-channel experience could
look like now I want to give you an
example of what a digital strategy could
look like as part of an omni-channel
experience in a physical store one of
the pioneers here is Barney's in New
York in fact then the brant the first
round to create this kind of digital
customer experience their new flagship
store in downtown Manhattan uses a
complex personalization platform that
allows them to send our editorial
content that is personalized to each
basically you can sign up for
personalized notifications for
location-based shopping and for
notifications with special offers and
store happenings what's really cool here
is the location-based shopping
experience basically Barney's can track
your behavior while you're online see
what's in your mobile shopping bag what
wish lists you have and you're browsing
patterns within their stores online
publication where this knowledge
Barney's can then send push
notifications to those shoppers as they
get close to their store or already
inside there'll be notified of events
like what offers but the most impressive
thing about it is that then actually be
getting personalized notifications once
they get physically close to items that
are in their mobile shopping bag floor
on their wish lists this makes for a
completely new type of experience with
shoppers and it also helps Barney's make
more sales as customers are basically
being directed towards the exact
products that interested the buyer is
New York digital so start again the
Bahamas New York flagship store truly
gives us a glimpse into what is most
likely the future of an integrated
online and offline shopping experience
I have an overwhelmed and managed to
explain or only what an omni-channel
strategy is but also have given you an
idea of where you can get started with
implementing your own omni-channel
marketing is clearly the next logical
step in marketing is what it customers
expect really and there's no way around
classic can get you better results your
customers will be happier will make more
sales more conversions and you'll have
less disgruntled customers this is what
you need to remember the need for
personalization a seamless transition
across different channels and perhaps
most importantly that the customers
should be at the center of all of your
marketing everything you do you should
keep the customer in mind omni channel
marketing is also a great tool for
improving your overall roi by creating a
strategy with a customer in mind where
they get the best possible experience
every time they interact with your brand
you will manage to improve royalty and
generally build stronger relationships
with your customers and the more you are
able to do that well the better you'll
return on investment social media is a
huge part of a strong omni-channel
strategy and I hope that you now have
the information you need to start
integrating social mediums or other
marketing channels and I now welcome
questions thank you you like that was
wonderful that was wonderful we have
some great questions coming in I do need
to go ahead if you can go ahead and go
one slide forward please and then before
we start the question-and-answer i'm
actually going to take over the screen
here and we have a poll that we always
do at the beginning of the question and
answer basically if you are interested
in continuing education and getting
certified and some of the wonderful
courses simply learn you can go in and
click on the pole and it will connect
you with some buddies they can answer
more questions and you can get something
more specific in the simply learn arena
we have some great questions coming in
from let's start with a set tendra i
hope i said
name right she has some questions
concerning a newly launched products so
if we have a newly launched products how
does the omni channel is it beneficial
for newly launched products and what are
the top three things one needs to keep
in mind while creating a user experience
for the first time customer and for
newly launched products if you're just
starting a new launch product and you
have your first customer what would be
the top things you would suggest for
that I think it's about knowing your
customer I think the rules apply
regarded regardless of whether it's a
new business or an existing business i
think more you know about your customer
the best route is so that you can
provide a seamless experience for them
so i would ensure that if you're
launching something new that you
listening and being able to monitor what
they're saying so that you don't miss
any brand mentions because to damage
your reputation initially is something
something you want to try and avoid i
would also make sure that you have
really clear guidelines because
sometimes it's actually easier starting
at the beginning rather than having a
big company and thousands of employees
because things get cross and there's a
lot more training involved so if you
have a new business and you have that
opportunity to put things in place to
make sure that everybody is a line that
everybody knows that procedures there's
clear guidelines on what you can can't
do and that everything is shared across
throughout all the teams involved hmm
nice um question here what if we money
is always a big thing I've worked with a
lot of startups and I tell you the
budgets everybody asks about the budget
we don't have the budget for a fall
omni-channel strategy is there anything
we can do where have you how can you
bite off little pieces to give a startup
company don't want to spend a lot of
money how do you do that how do you take
care of that well i think you know you
don't have to have big budgets i mean
obviously disney is it it's a crazy
example but it just shows how a line
they've had it
I think it boils down to have it
investing in good tools to help you so
you know having a really good measuring
at listing tool so that you can hear
what people are saying when they're
saying and investing the time into
training your staff because it's the
staff who are representing your brand
and making sure that everybody is really
aligned everybody knows that you know
these are the rules you know the custom
isn't happy what you can do and how you
can help them so that they don't get
passed from pillar to pillar it's so
frustrating as a consumer having that
issued so I think making sure that you
know everything is aligned and
everything is consistent and that you
have a strategy in place which focuses
on the resources that you have so for
example there's no point coatings
amazing strategy if actually when you
get down to it you just don't have the
resources in place to carry it out so
it's not just about the budget it's the
resources that you have as well so it's
setting realistic expectations and
creating goals and a vision of where you
want to be and working back to how
you're going to get there hmm excellent
excellent I could have used that advice
many years ago and i want to start ups
hindsight's twenty-twenty right we have
a question coming in on the b2b industry
I guess they're asking is do you have
any examples of how the omni-channel
works in a b2b industry say for example
IT consulting or IT services industry so
i guess if they have a back-end where
they're working with other companies to
be their support what kind of
omni-channel have you seen something
like that with the omni-channel is
integrated with their company and I
guess the company they're working with
um oh that's a really good question and
because I think my examples are a not b
to b which it was just highlights that
be to be a much better behind with it
than the consumers and no I can't
an example but I think I think actually
you should take the good examples you
know the likes of Disney who are doing
it well because just because regardless
of the industry and the space there in I
would only look at good examples because
it beat me to be is failing here yeah
they're not managing to master this and
that's because they don't value the
customers enough you know whither comes
with an consumer market without the
consumers they have no business and also
it's a really big volume business
whereas with a b2b you know they if they
have an unhappy customer they just get
another one you know they retained rate
is very different because word of mouth
is very different if you're not happy in
a b2b environment you don't tend to
complain as much as you do with the
consumer so they're getting away with it
but that's going to change because more
people will not put up with it so I
think just follow the steps of how the
b2c market is doing because they are
much more ahead than will be to be hmm
exit to me that sounds like a great
start up for a company just for your own
marketing maybe you maybe you're onto
something there vasantha maybe there may
be a whole nother industry yeah I wish I
had a nice on couch fine find an example
cuz that yeah I'm curious to see if
there is any one good I can't think of
anything off the top of my head but that
would be a good sales point though for a
b2b industry if they can identify not
only their customer but the end customer
and sell that any that would think I
said I'd be a great idea for a start-up
coming down we have how can we get
different departments to work together
as part of an omni-channel strategy so
you have a large company how do you get
everybody to come together for that it
sounds like a major project yeah well
first you need to come up with your only
channel strategy and then when it's time
to implement it you have to gather our
all of you know your different
department heads to explain what their
strategy actually
is all about and you're really going to
need to have some kind of centralized
system where all the different
departments can easily access it and so
they can leave notes for other
departments and so on so that everything
is you know easily communicated and I
think that the best way to go about it
is to invest in cloud computing we can
keep everything to clear University our
angel so that everyone in your team can
see past conversations you know
history's that's happened the customers
make notes and that sort of thing so
that this way whenever somebody
interacts with a customer in any way
they have to check a central database
beforehand and after completing the
interaction then they then must make
sure that they add notes or any
important information and i think that
there also needs to be somebody managing
this process because so that things
don't get lost so that you know it's
cactus it's quite strictly working hmm
excellent excellent let's see we have a
question coming in which approach do you
see working better for regulated product
industry and I'm not quite sure they
need my regulated product industry I
hope you know what that means
multi-channel or omni-channel I maybe
discuss a little bit what regulated
product industry is if you know what
that is um oh that's a really good
question as well has a really great
question sighs um I mean I I always
believed in in an omni-channel anywhere
because I think that's the future I
think that's where the direction we're
heading as as customers you know is to
have a seamless personalized experience
it's all about building relationships
and making sure that the whole journey
is linked from wherever you are so I
would recommend that excellent
let's see what types of businesses
should get started with the omni channel
marketing which ones do you see that are
really taking off with that well um one
of the types of businesses that would
really benefit the most from Romney
channel marketing strategy of those in
meter so like we're seeing in amazon has
Senate Barneys New York in retail you
can make much more personalized
recommendations based on past behavior
and you can obviously then integrate
that digit clean with your bricks and
mortar store and but you know that's
said most any type of business would
work great with omni channel marketing
because it really helps enhance the
customer experience excellent um another
question coming in here I think we have
time for about one maybe two more
questions if we implemented an
omni-channel strategy would we need any
dedicated employees that we need to work
full-time on this so what kind of
resources would need to be invested in
an omni-channel strategy and not
necessarily but it does depend a lot on
Morton strategy is and what kind of
technology you're going to use it so you
might need someone working on it full
time in the beginning just to help you
get everything set up the goal is to get
everyone in all your different
departments working as part of your own
omni-channel strategy excellent and one
last question and if you have questions
and we were missed them you can
definitely visit the simply learn forum
if you go to ww simply learn com you can
scroll down you'll see community or you
can go to directly to it which is
community simply learn calm and on there
you can actually go in there and post
your question directly and I just
switched it back oh there we go okay you
can post your question directly to the
forum we do have a lot of experts to go
in there and answer many marketing
questions We certainly have both a
masters program and other programs
available in the different marketing
arenas and I said lots of experts you
can go in there and answer those
questions
I'm going to bring up one last question
for the day what are the biggest
challenges with implementing an
omni-channel strategy oh gosh I think
you know one of the biggest challenge is
definitely the budget um I mean that say
is you know this is an issue and you're
interested in getting extensive
technology like you know for examples
barneys new york or own hair salon
another issue is simply put the
creativity signs you really need to
think outside of the box in order to
find the perfect ways to be able to
blend your different channels and it can
also be quite difficult to get all of
your different departments to
collaborate constantly especially if
your company is quite big or if the
departments are quite segregated
excellent we do have to go ahead and
close because we are at the end of the
hour Leela I really want to thank you
for your time today is a wonderful
webinar I love these things I'm always
learning something new and we suddenly
have a craving for danishes with
frosting three of them on a tray I don't
know where that came from I think that
was I think that was like a half way
through on the motel one that the
danishes again thank you for being here
I thank everybody for showing up you
know wonderful and simply learn our the
or benefactor for these webinars they
sponsor these and it's not a small
production in the back so you know take
the time to visit simply learn calm at
the very least you can visit community
simply learn calm which is an open forum
and ask some questions or of experts I'm
actually in the programming and big data
side so you might see my picture in
there if that's what you're interested
in and you have questions along that
that line like the Hadoop and spark
framework we have some glee over over a
thousand in people who are connected as
trainers who look at that web
right so a lot of professionals go in
there again thank everybody for showing
us and li lick I wish you a wonderful
day and I look forward to working with
you again sometime thank you so much
great speed Evans the opportunity take
care everybody and goodbye for today and
happy learning
you